Bastien
[Applaudissements]
résolu il retrouvait Dominique molle 3
ans après seul les bêtes ou les jouets
un gendarmes qui étaient lui naïf et
souriant mais qui ne veut de Joséphine
Baker on a découvert à l'écran 2011 dans
la guerre et déclarée de Valérie
Donzelli
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci beaucoup j'ai vu qu'une
minute ça allait très vite donc je vais
essayer d'aller très vite un César pour
avoir gardé espoir
même si j'imagine que
le plus dur est encore à venir Dominique
je pense à toi très fort à cet instant
au montagne qui t'environnent à celles
qui nous entouraient pendant le tournage
dans lesquels on a marché avec Carole
Caroline et Barbara les productrice que
je salue chaleureusement mais surtout
amicalement je pense à
toute l'équipe du film toutes celles et
ceux avec qui on sait frôlé avec
concentration et bienveillance pendant
ces semaines et c'est moi de travail je
pense à mes partenaires
dont les paroles
construisaient mais mes silences je
pense bien évidemment à toi bouli
et puis bon voilà bon
voilà c'est la
bon je pense évidemment
vous imaginez que je pense aux gens que
j'aime mais je remercie tout
particulièrement ce soir
l'équipe de fesses
[Applaudissements]